okay people joining our livestream we
are looking at updates to the data set
function can we get some background
noise here beautiful um okay okay so
we're gonna start off talking about
computational stuff and them are gonna
go to talking about rendering stuff all
right
yeah yes so one of the first things we
have discussed a few times is how to
provide headers independently of the
data like you have an array data and you
have to specify you want to specify the
head of another yes
well I think the issue with data set
let's remind everybody that the long
term vision of data set is that can be
backed by things other than in-memory
data so for example data set you should
be able to take a you know a relational
database and say data set of that I'm
making sense and that has the other
information so um what would you imagine
here I mean this is more like an this is
more like this um I mean you know
there's there's headers on the first
level the second level
etc right exactly yes so then yeah
here's that sometimes we have to say an
array of data which is a packed array of
data and then we want to treat it
together with its headers
I personally think that should be
another function like array data set
because I think data set itself I'm not
certain but I think data set itself is
gonna end up being needed I mean this
this then will be an array here that
will be the first level I mean this is
this is our association I mean this is
exactly our thing for turning an array
into an association isn't it yes but the
problem is that if we include the
headers as
Association the inner levels are going
to repeat the keys multiple times well
okay that's not like oh and and that's
problematic in terms of blowing up
memory Exeter well it shouldn't be I
mean that we should be we should be
handling that issue separately I see
you're saying this is a way to put in
head as independent of what the Reverend
terminal representation is but if we say
normal of that data set we better get
the nested Association thing yes yeah at
the moment we can go back to our
standard representation but I think if
if we managed not to have to change the
data that would be better so I should be
able to treat as data set as a black box
which has different types of internal
representation we need to try
with them Todd and the folks who are
doing out of memory stuff okay because I
don't think data set of relational
database doesn't work yet but it
probably will yeah this is effectively
the same idea it's just from the point
of view of the internal representation
rather than from the point of view of
how you can find I don't disagree with
that
yes so another thing that we would like
to change here is the fact that data set
this use internally several caching
methods so we would like to unify that
it's completely crazy I mean the other
thing is that this business about data
sets not storing themselves in notebooks
is crazy so Chris will talk about that
so Chris has to say yeah I've already
I've already implemented that yeah okay
good okay yes so we also need the
extensions for a query language so more
operators in particular they
column-oriented operations so we have
discussed several times yeah I think
that's a general discussion about column
stuff which we need to have separate
right exactly yes but it's going to be
especially important for for data sets
what is meant by column-oriented
operations there's an opossum map
something like that or whatever the
right way to do that is okay
acting on columns of objects of elements
not rose um okay data
on the functions so what do you mean by
on well I was suspecting that we would
be able to both its data set acting on a
time series and doing something with it
so that we can use it as a data set so
that I think because time series is
another important data container I think
we need that way of making but by the
way can we make sure that the next I'll
be meeting we talk about that what do we
call it um not time series but but yes
dated series mm-hm
it should be rather straightforward but
I think we need to talk about it okay
yes so we need to make data sex act on
more data containers and also more
functions act on data set objects which
is yes but I don't quite understand how
time series would flow into data set
do we understand that yet so in other
words given a time series well yeah go
ahead yes so I don't have a proposal yet
so I understand that somehow time series
a continuous object but sometimes we
will have like no the data for a time
series could very well be a data set
could be turned into a data set yeah and
a data set certain columns of a data set
could turn into a time series yes
perhaps we need here some parity
argument oh that's good point yeah so
yeah so here we have discussed more
functions that should to work with with
it a set and you have sensor yes stands
like this one right
yes um yes under on the live stream is
asking about terabyte size data sets the
answer is yes using I mean we have
basically three strategies we have the
relational database stuff which I think
we should be able to just implement that
I mean I think that's a pretty
straightforward hook up which I think
you need to talk to Todd and the
database people about guys where we just
say database of a relational database
and it should just you should be able to
do data set operations on that and not
all of them will work it'll say some of
them it'll say you know warning warning
you know has to be read into memory to
make this work
right think sense yes and I'm sure we
will learn some new operations to extend
the query language from right but I mean
I think I don't even know and it's a
good question and Sushma this is one for
you to follow up on given a relational
database object how do you just read it
in as a data set I don't know how you do
that I don't know whether import works
on it or what the heck works on it well
so I think import to say but to read
like access files but I mean the point
point is once you've already got it
hooked up you've already got things
chosen and all that kind of stuff
there's something which should just
bring it in as data set and I think
probably that the data set function
itself should leave it on disk right
sure or leave it in database land and do
operations aren't in so far as it can
but there needs to be a way of just
getting the thing raw as a data set so
that you are and maybe there's an option
to say whether it's going to be local or
not right okay so then the other thing
is the file based data set business
okay so that is Leonids chunk creature
and that needs to be explored so the
belief is okay so so just I mean I want
to add a comment here well here we go
lazy out of course computation so one
thing there is relational database
another thing there is file backed with
CSV hdf etc right and the final one is
spa compact which is distributed a
distributed database which we keep on
starting to work on and then stopping
working on which sparked no Dylan B was
was working under one point but if that
project has been hibernated right Sushma
yes um okay so this one should be rather
easy now okay and and in particular
people are gonna bleat that the
operations in data set don't map
perfectly into the operations that you
can do on database well tough luck right
um okay this one here as I say leonid
got a long way with this we didn't
finish it um sandal on the live stream
is supporting the file backed one but
I'd like to know what file format you'd
like because CSV it's very uh novice
what you know seeking around in a CSV
file is complicated um I'm not sure how
we imagine we're going to do that but
you know that's what leonid that's well
in its thing leonid is building you know
a snake processor as in it's like you
know it's a thing where it's like the
snake eating and answer
or something you know it it I keep on
using this analogy it's really stupid
analogy but you understand what I mean
it's it's operating on one part of this
long file at a time it's chunk based
okay I think again
you guys should find out what the status
of that is because lien had built a lot
of stuff and then we killed that project
cause you couldn't understand the use
case
yeah Sandra is saying hdf5
well I agree but I'd like to know where
did the hdf5 files come from um and
that's really the the issue for us and I
think a good exercise there would be are
their data repository potential data
repository files data sources that come
in hdf5 that would be interesting to
know are the things that we want to put
in that where we could do it because
it's a terabyte or something but it's an
hdf5 that makes sense
that would be a good use case for us to
understand this and you know for lucky
um if we're lucky what leonid did like a
year ago will actually be immediately
usable here makes sense
so another thing i want to do is
effectively do rewrite reorganize this
page there damn yeah it's it's it's Wild
West mostly yeah um yeah
it has examples but they're Group C now
you understand their way yeah well let's
not do that
I mean and then work for a documentation
for the data set I agree and and
probably a monograph of some kind
okay and then yes so it has also been
suggested that we change a bit how then
error handling works I'm not sure about
that yet it has this option failure
action and yeah it's a bit non-standard
so I don't know what it's really doing
okay all right there are easier things
to do and these are kind of bigger
products well look the big big project
is linguistic interpretation for
datasets linguistic querying of datasets
and that's a project that I think should
get started but that's in the machine
learning group and the RP group right
and I really think they should try and
do that I've forgotten what Apache arrow
is it's some sort of common format based
on columns which is being used by is
similar data systems and it's it's
working quite well so there'll be a way
of interacting with other formats and
systems yeah well because this is an
import/export format or is it something
different I don't think it's more like a
format is it's it's it's some sort of
set of functionality to to help you
transform in between formats okay what
we need to understand a little bit
better so the semantic interpreter that
can return there's a proper types I mean
semantic interpreter is not that to me
like is a lower priority thing because I
think that um you know that's really
taking our curation tools and being able
to flow them into data set and that's a
complicated project I think that that's
not really best done as a single
one-shot function because I think
there's so much messiness in reading in
data
and again I don't think it's for this
you know for you guys to do this okay
all right should we move over to this
yeah so you should set that path and
right why did it just run your and as oh
I see it was in two cones anyway yeah
okay
okay so so part of the purpose here is
to set priorities and partners to go
over some issues along the way I hope we
can do both well it's a bit mad yeah
because this is implemented a branch
that you don't have you just wiped out
the output okay dang there it is right
that's just to show you what the output
looks like
so the story this at the top well that's
one of the issues we should discuss I I
just took the the button that we have
for the summary box stuff and pasted it
on the top here I think it should blend
well if it's a long data set you might
not see it but I've asked designed to
come up with a Sibelius here right now
right yes and I was hoping we could look
at some of the use cases of data set or
some of the examples by the way it's not
gonna be that long because it's a paged
object if it's not paged you did
something different and don't worry
about it see what I'm saying so you
think we should just hang it under the
bottom like well I think we should hang
it onto the bottom like we do for all
the other types of objects so there's
nothing for design to do then here I
think not in this case okay I mean
unless Billy unless you have a brilliant
idea I just don't think it's a great I
don't think it's necessary
I mean it's paged for goodness sake
right they'll be plenty a lot of things
for you to do do not worry okay but did
you have a version of this perhaps that
we could look at instead of branch oh
you did Billy at mock-ups you mean yeah
no no I haven't even got a chance to get
to it okay I'm fine all right
so if there are multiple columns in this
data set should the data not in notebook
be of the same length same width I mean
I should you made us a dataset as a thin
that's a design issue I mean if this
thing is very square yes
I mean one of the features okay let me
tell you a couple of designers whose
well you're probably about to talk about
that items displayed in scrolling look
okay my my basic point is this should be
at the bottom the details of how it
spans is another question right so Billy
has to pay attention to that okay okay
so there are a couple of other issues
for the limit that determines when it
stores the data in notebook and one or
not I'm using the summary box data size
limit is that okay or you think we need
a different symbol for that let's just
say it's the same thing I think it's
okay
I think it's okay I think that what's
that well the symbol is not named
ideally for you to use it for for data
set but no it isn't is that a documented
symbol documented it is god I wish we
had is that on a priority list know that
the auto completion of this thing I can
check but I don't recall it being there
well we could argue that this is a
summary box I don't think it's
hopelessly different from the summary
books no it's very much the same kind of
thing okay I think you can use that for
the time and then I've currently only
implemented this the store notebook
button if you're at the top level if
you're not if you're drill down yes I
think that's right okay good
okay items displayed and scrolling right
so there's currently two different
options rows displayed and columns
displayed if we want to generalize that
to be able to specify the number of
items at any level then I think that the
option used to be come
I think that's right I think you already
and this is a syntax I'm proposing you
if you say items display R is the number
of top-level rose and if you give Arceus
rows and columns top level and then you
can you can specify are C and then paths
to inner levels what does that mean well
so that means that things and the moon's
column in that case there would be two
items displayed so you don't you don't
know our priori if it's gonna be rows or
columns right so sorry I understand the
rows the thing is intense ax okay
this is the top-level index to the
tensor which is usually displayed as
rows the second-level index of the
tensor usually displays columns and this
here is a deeper aspect right but I
almost found the moon's part of that so
well so if this is referring to the
planets data set all right let's look at
so there's a that can example data open
open curly first yeah data set comma
planets
what is good okay okay so if you hover
over the moon's column header you'll see
that index all moons yes so if you
specify that index that says display two
items what the hell is that
that is a placeholder just so if you if
you right-click on look at the font that
no it's it's you just ignore it it's
just a it's a temporary placeholder
because you've rewritten yo your code is
overwritten what I normally do yes
yes okay fine right okay so this means
for the moon's index I only want to see
two items I understand why this is okay
for the rows the columns you're counting
numerically the rows Boom Boom Boom Boom
Boom down so so you could get away with
just always specifying an index right
but I thought it was most uses are gonna
be for the top level so it seems to be
useful to have a little syntactic no no
I agree my question is I don't
understand this is about a deeper level
because the rows and columns does this
work by the way can I can I use the
items displayed thing you can use rows
displayed and columns displayed okay Oh
so you have to do it by rapat you have
to do data sales data set of normal
should I not worry about the red yeah I
don't worry about it okay
that did exactly what I would expect
okay now if I say okay so now what are
you doing with me you you can't
currently the lower level things are not
implemented yet you can only do top
level with rows displayed in columns
displayed right now okay but if I said
columns displayed
- then moons is just blowing away right
okay well you get a scroll bar you can
scroll to it okay fine okay okay okay
fair enough
I mean you can you can do that there and
see how it works okay
so for this wood that store button
appear below those scroll bars are to
the right because it looks smaller it
looked like a change for a moment it
looked like what changed maybe it was
just the zoom the meeting refreshing
yeah I don't think so
you know Seth on our live stream asked
something which I was also going to ask
which is what if you actually just want
to display only certain columns right my
address that under the next topic
collisions okay all right so I still
don't quite understand this all come a
moons goes to two what does that do so
that means you would only see two moons
so each each planet has a number of
moons you would only see two moons I see
so it's this level so this is
representing the next level but why
what's the all doing that's what you see
if you hover over the moon's header
that's the index of that column of that
level of the data set so this is column
three so yeah go ahead
that's what about what did I want two
moons but what have another piece what
if column two was also something that
was you know artificial satellites or
something right right
then you would then you would specify
curly all comma satellites arrow two or
three or four whatever with it they're
just free form and this I don't have
done isn't this positional Rose column
after rows and columns okay I see your
confusion after rows and columns it's
not positional it's just you give you
give the path to the level on the data
set and the number of items law that's
what I was that's what I was saying
about the syntactic sugar law otherwise
you're going to have to specify a path
for the row and a path for the column
no but what you're saying is this is a
path and that's saying how many of those
keys it isn't just this it's not just
this this moons thing I see that goes to
an association all comma moons if I
would look here at this example data and
I were to say all comma moons okay I
will get this okay now why is the two
wise there are two here the two means
display two moons for each planet yeah
but why I mean if I look at what this is
let's say um well let's say I just do
take that comma for the table Oh where's
Mars is moons I understand why didn't
that do it by row why didn't that take
the first four rows and what happened to
Mars as mountains I don't know that
could there may be a bug in my prototype
I wouldn't describe it but I'll check it
out in them okay but fine but if I did
that I'm utterly confused at what this
is doing well let's turn it around if
you only want to see two moons for each
planet how would you specify that sorry
I think the moon's are still there you
have to click in the one total and two
total yeah but I don't know why it
formatted it differently in that case I
wanted them without displaying it and it
also didn't show yeah something that
there may be my bug in the prototype
right okay fine
[Music]
okay the issue is what you're trying to
do here is to select in this stack of
lists and associations you are trying to
[Music]
take certain subsets there or for the
beginning you're just trying to do a
take show me you know like like for
example I might want to see the last 10
columns I might want to see a span of
columns I might want to see particular
columns I'm saying yeah so I might want
you know items displayed you know I
might want five through eight right or I
might want items displayed and then a
sub list here you know something like
one two four
you know seven ten
[Music]
um okay so that's that only specified
I'm so confused here I mean you're
saying I go down a tentacle of the data
set I see I see
so given the clock on the data set
you're asking when you get to the end of
that path you would normally have lots
of stuff to show right but in fact only
show a part of it so in particular the
full form of this would be the path that
you're showing here is the full form of
this is all arrow that the full form of
this next one is well I don't really
know what it is is it all comma all goes
to whatever what is the full form of the
next one and if you can tell me that
then I'm going to be more interested
[Music]
don't know why friend okay but that's
what we have to figure out because we're
not gonna go for this I mean what this
is saying is with that path the next
thing you get to show only two of them
right yeah now I could also be saying
you here that I what I want is instead
of just showing two of them it's
essentially a take spec of some kind I
could be showing say you know damos you
know Ganymede whatever couldn't die I
hadn't anticipated doing that but I
suppose well I mean that's only going to
apply to
oh you're picking out moons that could
be in any planet I see I see I see I see
I see I see well so that's not
necessarily right but okay so that's not
correct I think the problem here is that
we are using simultaneously part of ex
extract expects and take aspects it's
yeah well right I mean but but the the
basic form should be um extract spec
arrow take spec or some version of take
spec that's what it should look like and
there is an illusion
perhaps that allows you to give the
levels without without specifying
explicit extract specs so I think the
answer to your question earlier was so
for ROS the left hand side is is I don't
know empty and for columns the spec is
all so it would be an empty list for ROS
and then just a list of column or a list
of all
four columns lies a list of all wasn't
just all well so four moons it's all
common loons right and one level up is
just I don't think this is right
I I think it's all here because I think
that this is I think what's meant was
the first all is an empty list yes yeah
the first ones the first all in your
statement there is an empty list the
next row is a list that contains just
all yeah and potential it could be it
could be three and that means focus only
on the third I don't completely
understand this but you get where I'm
going with this I think that they look I
think this basic idea is reasonable I
think we have to figure out how to do it
let me go on to the illusion thing
because the things that's going to be um
so elisions are mostly implemented in
the prototype if you right click on a
column header there's a control to hide
or show which is which and works with us
that's super cool
so you can say hide there and it will
give you a lip sees the right you should
be able to Mouse down on that say show
but it's um you know it drilled down
that's interesting I think it's a book
you must have single clicked so one
question is should there be a top level
option which corresponds to this
interactive behavior I've called the
deletions for now another question yes
absolutely
okay now the question is should one be
able to I think there's an argument that
you should not be able to that you
should not be able
just remove columns from the display
completely I mean yeah in other words
that everything that you get here is
something where you're still left with a
paddle with which to or so to speak yeah
there that was my next question
I think so I mean I think so I'm not
certain but I think you know having the
scroll bars having the plus signs I kind
of think that's the right approach to
say this thing really is all the data
you're not actually you know you might
be hiding some of it but you're not
removing something right if you want to
project the data you do that if the data
said exactly yes they said yeah right
but I absolutely think this should be
available top-level now I think that
there's an argument that and I don't
know between items displayed and actual
items elided I mean we can't call it
illusions it's going to be items
displayed it's we should say items are
lighted or something like that
or items not alighted as the case may be
I'm not sure if we need to that's we
need to get to that in a minute okay
let's look at this okay but what do you
mean by alights you just mean does
things like this right because then yeah
no no all's thing Muhammad on the
livestream is saying that dollar
illusion threshold does not work do you
know anything about that I don't know
what that is that a dataset thing says
dataset backtick dollar illusion
threshold sounds relevant
it sure does but I'm not familiar with
it great um okay well sounds like that's
the thing to look at okay
um I want to talk a little bit about
table view are you going to talk about
that somewhere here I don't have it on
the list but we can talk about it
so my understanding from John is the
table view is a low-level control object
right so what our relationship to data
set is it may be a way of implementing
data sets so the scrolling is faster
because it's a it's a low-level simple
object it doesn't do all the formatting
stuff that grid does okay but there's
another point about it which is editable
right on data set is not yes and I don't
think should be yeah I would think I
would agree with that currently the only
question for me is whether we can
implement data set using table view and
whether we whether there's a real
advantage to doing that and John is
going to update the documentation for
table view so that I know what's there
and then let me know as I've been do
some tests on that right but I think
that's the only that's the only question
currently that I'm considering
concerning their relationship between
well I think that table view it could be
that some of the mod cons modern
conveniences of data set will be you
know the fact that it's used as a nice
display format you know I don't know we
need to understand more about table view
meets data set um yeah Ethan our lives
tableview will be super cool yeah but
it's going to be really complicated
because of all these drill downs and non
you know non-rectangular edges and
things like this but I mean the whole
point of tableview is to be simple so
they can be efficient yeah yeah but
that's yeah right
I mean it's complicated okay so Seth is
pointing out that it would be nice to be
able to do string matching on which rows
you want to elide like elide every row
that is yeah incidentally if I allied
multiple rows oh I see that's not great
you know we really should have I think a
merging Elida if you understand what I
mean but then if you get a bunch of
stuff merged the only way you have to
open them all at once right you can't
open them back individually right that
the question is okay so that's one thing
merge religions and the second thing is
controlling collisions by name also of
column or by content so I actually had
an implementation that did that and I
jettisoned that because you can if
you're allowed these fancy
specifications you can specify non
rectangular areas within a data set and
that complicates things immensely so
it's very expensive to implement that
that's why that's why I'm restricting
this to a very simple syntax well wait a
minute if you're killing it for killing
a row yeah yeah good okay so to case
well if you say if you say things that
match one in this case you've got a row
and a column and that gives you an
alighted area so it may not be so bad
and then I I don't think it's the that's
not the right thing
I think you need to say given the keys
of a particular set of keys at a
particular level do they match such and
such right and that's well defined it's
purely rectangular slicing x' okay and
that that would be fine okay and I think
it's also true that given the payload of
one of these like let's say most of them
are missing you might want to relied
that column see what I'm saying yeah so
I mean I think that there's an argument
that says um you know I could imagine I
don't know if this is right but
something like name function content
function I don't know if this is right
but something like this or key key name
key function function
so the right hand side would be a an
association with this that's what I'm
suggesting yes okay
I mean it's let's keep going but I want
to come back to this and I also am
concerned about merging evolutions
because I could imagine a thing where
you've just got rid of a huge amount of
stuff right I think that's fine the only
downside is you have to open them back
up all at once right but so I think
there's the notion of left mirja Boleyn
right merger bowl what do you mean by
that well I mean could it be enough just
to make them very thin so that it would
it would be yes it would be I mean if
they're if they're multiple ones next to
each other I mean I don't know well
that's feasible to make these very very
thin yeah well I can make it just the
width of the plus essentially first week
there's no put no space then for an
ellipsis but yeah but you could do that
if there are many next to each other I
think Billy I think from a design point
of view I I do not like the the
asymmetry here anyway yeah I would
prefer to see no white space here just a
pure plus centered plus and then
ellipses down down there
what can you click the ellipses you
should be able to to drill down yeah I
would think so why wouldn't you be able
to click the ellipses well I mean if you
click you just click the three to the
left doesn't do anything because it's a
leaf if it wasn't a leaf it would drill
right over here yeah but if that's
alighted what are you clicking oh it's
like here no no it doesn't drill unless
it's a key right
surgery we always need to show the
ellipses
if you can't drill down into them now if
it's gonna better really think all and
it could just be blank right just yeah I
don't see why it shouldn't be blank and
then maybe could you then hover over the
whole column and some effect would
happen they click and you can expand it
I would've thought so yeah you can just
click the plus and it'll show it but but
I think that that hovering should work
elsewhere too
whoops right you have to right-click to
get the menu okay well if somebody
helped me help hoped I would understand
the random piece of Python code in the
live stream I'm sorry I do not so if
somebody else does all good but I do not
um to write it ins of my which are
pseudo orphan language I might
understand it
you
you
you
can't mate arrived columns and datasets
and parallel threads not yet no that's a
different story I mean that's that that
is using
it would be interesting to understand
what what that really involves and
whether in fact what that really is is
something where effectively you are
looking in our story of relational
database file back to terror etcetera
etcetera I think there's another case
which is kind of you know virtual data
sets with computed columns which we
don't have
I mean entity store has that has the
notion of computed values but data set
does not that makes sense
where the column isn't really there
right it's computed on demand then it
could be computed on a parallel kernel
or whatever else um I do agree that
computer data sets is interesting
virtual computer data sets is
interesting as I say entity stores do
have that notion I mean not for today
but I mean the way that would work is a
data set when you do an operation it
would look to see whether you need to
you know compute more values or fetch
more values or whatever to get into that
okay so look I I think my conclusion
from this is let's try the idea of just
having a thin column without a list
without ellipses yeah for the hidden
thing okay yep umm okay and when
something is elided I mean this one
total well I don't you know
yeah that's currently a different kind
of illusion yeah I mean
it's more an illusion that would be like
a you know why isn't this top level rose
why isn't that alight at the same way
these are know what I'm saying well as
if you're I mean that's handled with
scroll bars right yeah but this doesn't
have a scroll bar I mean this could have
a scroll bar as well like well internal
scroll bar here yeah in theory it could
be an internal scroll bar instead of
that control the problem is in order to
implement that we have to have nested
grids and they don't visually they don't
nest nicely and they see I mean because
just because it looks really weird to
have well you you can't make things put
up against each other you get extra
pixels here and there but it can't be
implemented in a single grid because if
the scroll bar is within the grid which
is being reconstructed by the scroll bar
you lose tracking I see what you're
saying okay but I mean in principle this
mechanism could be used at the outer
level it could thing right and arguably
that should be an option yeah that's one
of the items on the further down in that
notebook is how things are alighted okay
this is I don't this is just an item
that I don't have any tests from tally
tally could not provide me with any so I
need to spend some time putting together
tests especially since he have any no he
doesn't what about what about um what's
his name the guy who took over this some
guy in the Boston office the one who
worked with Jose well I don't remember I
mean he didn't stay long but who was
that ya know I thought that
a person who tally who was working with
tally who was working on data set with
tally maybe yeah yeah who be shocked I
think we shouldn't be shocked yes that's
the person yes yes yes that's the person
right so and what does QA have in terms
of tests
well yeah I haven't asked you a well you
better ask him this Shaq would be the
other person look at his commits and ask
you a yeah obviously we need tests but
we need tests for you and for Qi I'm
assuming QA has a bunch of tests so
there may be some confusion here okay so
I've implemented one kind of header
control but there are other
possibilities you should just open up
that entire section there's right so one
possibility is to put this explicit
button if you click date it would drill
down if you click the button that drops
down the menu another class I'm confused
I'm confused I'm confused you know the
date button yeah what is real this is
just a mock-up of join us I'm aware with
this button go in a header so to the
right there for example next to mass so
the question is do your lab it's
currently implemented with a right click
I get it let's get it I met it with an
explicit button what you actually asked
for initially was a hover menu which is
a third option the problem is we don't
currently have the technology to do that
because our hover menus have to be
dismissed with an explicit click if you
hover over that date anything go away it
won't good menu won't go away until you
click which is bad
but I think if the menu would dismiss
when you leave the menu then that would
be a nice alternative I think that's
right when I talked to John about that
yeah um look in this case you know the
sort up sort down and so on needs to be
indicated there I think it is actually
if I if again if you go and that menu
you can you can choose sorting and it
shows an almost identical icon which
would be confusing okay all notes as
essential link to the QA dataset tests
ok um so my preference here I kind of
like this idea of hover menus so if we
have hover menus and to drill down that
would ever be a menu item you couldn't
actually click on the header' item yeah
sounder is pointing out on touchscreens
what happens
and holes I guess or something Bellini
thoughts about that the touch in case I
think you would have to be a tap to
activate so tap would activate the menu
and then another tap to dismiss the menu
yeah I don't know who would have to show
in a less standard menu or if it would
be a notebook thing
what about drill down well you just go
to drill down menu okay you tap tap you
get the menu you decide what to do now I
mean we could have a double click before
you know I think it will be nice if we
were able to enable double click to
drill down and hover to bring up a menu
if that's possible we should investigate
that I think it would be preferable to
having a lot of weird and I think what
should happen is that the if it's a
non-standard sorting it should display
an icon that indicates the non-standard
sort rather than displaying by default
that you know anything happened I mean
in other words if you explicitly said to
sort then you know don't sort and
display anything which if you start
ascending or descending then it should
yeah go over to the example data on the
right and evaluate that again or click
back up to the top level yeah now so
just right click on a radius and there's
sort options there so you can that's
cool okay and then it displays this yeah
although now pressing that button once
you've displayed that thing pressing
that should take action yes it should
you have to currently press on the text
that's very cool that's very nice okay
so I think we have a good good story
there okay let's keep going
so again I want to come back up we don't
have a good solution for addressing you
know which items should be displayed at
cetera Sarasota so we're gonna come back
to that and which should be alighted
initially in the initial display I mean
another thing we don't have which would
be nice is a way of extending the range
here rather than just scrolling through
it it's like I just want to see a bigger
page see what I'm saying yeah and I
might suggest that we have a mechanism a
thing outside of the scrollbar that some
kind of opener that is the analog of
this opener here right that would just
give me you know some some UX thing that
just says show me more show me more show
me more similar to the mechanism for the
output size limiter yeah I mean I'd
really like that show me more show me
less right Billy any ideas for an icon
double double arrow is that is that for
the scroll bars or is that for the in
the table no no what I want to do is I
want to go you know I want to suppress a
plus type thing there and I wanted to go
out to Jupiter I want to press plus
again I want to go further out and and I
think we could even imagine an option
which controls how that how that going
out works
I mean I it's not obvious to me that
going out should be either linear or
exponential could mean could there be
some sort of jump button integrate and
then I'm not very familiar with the the
data set interface I'll have to get a
little bit more familiar with it but
that's not a better idea that the thing
you just drew is not a bad idea it's not
saying over here or you know it's like a
jump plus sign well we don't think we
want to use a plus because we're using
that well you might be able to use a
plus yeah I mean tab it down type thing
see see that showing one of three of
eight what you've got there is actually
totally confusing because what you've
got is some at the bottom you have
something which is paging forward but at
the left you have a scroll bar that is
also paging forward yeah me maybe rotate
I think that like I could just disappear
sorry which line that showing that whole
that whole bar and those controls so
that the the two innermost arrow
controls are replicated in the scroll
bar we could just add that go to first
and go to last also to the scroll bar or
they're not even really necessary
because if you just click at the top of
the scroll bar it goes to the first
position anyway but knowing that there
are eight objects is useful but that's
that that's the similar to the 27 total
yeah it could yeah
it's a comment on the livestream about
Jupiter labs UI for Python datasets it's
useful to have collapse expand or what
does it do
um tell us what it does we'd like to
know okay so the question here
well okay I think we've got something to
do on this let me keep going just
understand what the rest of the scope is
but there's something to figure out here
we got it we got to be able to have an
interactive way to expand what we're
seeing and that that should work in my
opinion horizontally and vertically yeah
and the fact that this is you know and
so maybe you're right maybe we get rid
of this control here the thing we're
losing but we could have it on a hover
here is the knowledge of the total
number going down yeah right well look
what we could do is this see this 61
total we could just have that two here
yeah 61 total and it has an arrow or it
has something a little bit more
elaborate than the arrow we could use
something more elaborate than the arrow
here because that's a drill down in this
case right at the top level there is it
isn't a drill down
it'd be at the top of the header was up
above mercury where it says 61 total or
whatever total I think we wanted it
maybe keep the similarity in the or or
because they're all at the bottom here
yeah yeah I mean this paging behavior is
quite nice
but but
is confusing because it conflicts with
the horizontal scrollbar show us and
it's really just replicated by the
vertical scrollbar there's no additional
functionality except that the vertical
scrollbar is kind of we'll okay fair
enough
though there is additional functionality
we'd have to put in the scrollbar we
have to put the go to end well I guess
night just you just well yeah you just
click on them all right well anyway so
maybe we get rid of that okay so I'll
get rid of it I just replace it now with
a non-functional total I mean clicking
it doesn't do anything it just displays
the total yeah I think it should only do
that if the problem is this is confusing
with respect to this if it wasn't for
that that's a nice feature so adding
these numbers related to the scrollbar
themselves perhaps they could appear
while you are interacting with a scroll
rush yeah that's an interesting idea
all right even live stream says for
datasets that are huge this collapse
expand all toggles between a collapsed
version it gives a draggable scrollbar
to zoom through the pages smoothly
I see so you know
words here what's that doing there
like expand maybe it's in the wrong
corner
what kind of expanding is it but I like
the idea of framing the whole thing and
not having those those those things just
hang out I guess you'd click expand it
would show this version sort of well but
except that if it's a huge data set you
don't want to show the whole thing yeah
but that expander could be a plus
expander that just goes you know that
just is the is the oh oh so so what if
it was okay so it says the total here
and then if they click the total and
then so right now you don't see this but
after they click the total then you see
these things and it's a big menu plus
maybe there's some more options here
well you're saying the scroll bars are
hidden until you click total right
because you're you're limiting the
amount displayed here I think that would
be weird who would know at a click
total in order to get the scroll bars
mmm so what's this do right now then
maybe I'm confused as to what this does
well so that shows you that that gives
you a window into the entire data set
data set the case of the sub data set is
different oh is that what that is
yes okay
let's keep going that was my kettle
right we've got some problems to solve
here but III personally visually I don't
particularly like those things hanging
out in free space around the data set
right they could be incorporated into
the frame like scroll bars usually are
but I like Jose's idea of bringing
numbers in only when right so you would
you would see a little annotation next
to the cursor that shows you like where
you are and then shows the total number
yeah but now this collapse whole thing I
don't quite understand what the point
there is that in our data sets you know
we don't have I don't know how well do
we scroll or do we page through the
thing well you can page with the buttons
the arrow buttons you can scroll with
the bar okay then I don't understand
what the what the collapsed version is
that maybe it's just a question how
faster can scroll you click the bottom
horizontal scroll buttons it doesn't
update the left-hand vertical scrollbar
that's totally dumb okay well if we're
getting rid of the buttons then we don't
have to worry about that
and what we need to do if the thing is
not showing everything here we really do
need to say we need to indicate that
there's more coming
bla bla bla total isn't that what the
scroll bar is tell you
I guess I just like to put like a dot
dot dot at the bottom or something to
make people make sure people are not
confused okay let's keep going
index header so here I'm I'm proposing
you should open up everything there I'm
proposing that we should have we should
show the indices of matrices and things
as as headers no not by default why not
because it's just not what you want in a
lot of cases it looks it makes it ugly
and makes it look like a spreadsheet the
plenty of cases where you don't want
that you might want that I think that
should be an option to do that and
arguably that should be a right-click
thing to say show indices okay a
right-click thing look if you mouse down
anywhere within the data set that's what
I'm thinking yeah or in the I strongly
don't think we should do this alright
well you can see my reasons down below
for wanting headers no those are just
for your convenience we got to figure
out a different way to do it with the
second argument specifying headers we
could put automatic there perhaps yes
perhaps I mean we could put it in you
know as I think there's got to be an
option to control having this because
you might want it for grows but not for
columns whatever else okay but I think
and there should be a nice UI way to
switch it on but it shouldn't be there
by default we just doctored we just
talked about this okay and you've had a
look at that already I thought it's
magnificent can I
operable yeah so is this what we want
sort and reverse sort I think that you
need to evaluate that again in order to
make those controls operable okay um but
you know for us sort and reverse sort of
the right names rather than sort up sort
down
yeah and what about for a lot sorting
you need to click the text well right
not sorted what do you think you think
unsought is a better term because it
only comes up if you have Gaza sorting
in yeah I've also has don't sword no
because that no that's different because
that that's not an action unless you're
thinking of
sort here as a noun but well everything
else is a verb I think it wants to be
unsought can we have arrows in there
that shows oh that's right I forgot that
thing appears but wait a minute this
this does sort the whole dataset right
it doesn't just yeah okay that's my name
if you have and you can sort multiple
things within a data set I mean if
they're not all the same level like if
you go to if you go to C now and sort
that then the sorting on B will
disappear because if you have separate
levels you can have sorting on different
levels right I mean in a perfect world
you would have sub sorting right in
other words you sought on B and then the
ties of B you can resolve some other way
[Music]
right so sandal on the live stream is
talking about how people call sort
ascending and sort ascending yeah I know
but I think sort and reverse so it makes
more sense given our function names I'm
not certain about that should make a
note
should consider ascending and descending
now that's a question of when the things
are in the tabular format how do they
truncate is that correct yeah whether
whether you show the like the 63 total
or something else well also if I've got
a giant mega thing for that cell what
does it do right because that's for
watching all right sorry it's not always
confuse you you're right that's what
we're talking about yeah okay well I
think this is some kind of display
function thing because I think that's
very similar to I mean in other words
it's like short right given a cell size
what do you actually show you see what
I'm saying yeah and then the question is
should the option match on the type of
the data or the level within the data
set or Oh somehow I think what should
happen is I would think that this is a
pretty detailed thing that most people
will not adjust and the best thing to do
will be to give it an association that
contains a bunch of information it
contains the actual thing you're
formatting you know content path you
might as well give the full path
well those are the two things that are
most interesting right yeah
humm
okay Ethan is saying all that a ribbon
style attached sell menu like for images
for doing what I mean there isn't a
action here like for images there's a
click action and the whole image is
selected and then you can bring up a
data set ribbon yeah right I mean that
would be an interesting thing to do but
it's not clear what brings it up because
with an image you click the image to
select the image and then it brings up a
ribbon um a little ribbon yeah
sounded by the way is saying in Excel
the ties are sorted as follows first
sort I see them by B yeah that's what I
thought if you want to sort by B and
then ties oh no no it's the other way
around okay and then okay but anyway
there's a multi there's a notion of
multiple column sorting there so I was
not wrong that there is that notion
right so in other words that you could
sort by multiple columns
you
um
Yeah right this Ethan is suggesting a
right-click to apply a function to
column B where you write your code in a
pop-up window I agree that that is quite
interesting that one of the menu items
there should be apply a function to this
column you determine how the contents
are displayed well potentially but I
think also there's the question of
actually doing operations on the data
set and having that reflected in the
data set data well I mean that's code
synthesis from this oh hold on let me
just um consider also tiebreaking ie
okay so here's a very naive question we
don't have a good mechanism we would say
if we said sort by right we could say
sort by certain hold on how to sort by
work doesn't it have a tie breaker
mechanism yes it does it has exactly
that tie breaker mechanism see yeah um
for what it's worth okay so those would
be those could be actually just names of
Association keys okay preserving
compound objects this is just
of specifying what should be treated as
atomic and not yes I understand but how
do you how you proposing doing it um I
don't I don't have our proposal yet this
is just an agenda item okay I agree that
that's necessary so I mean that that's
basically as the data set is constructed
that's the second argument the headers
argument should also say don't make this
into a you know somehow don't do the
drill down here yeah I get into data set
okay so we we had a meeting about this
once we and etre Minh there's a lot of
things to discuss here this is just
generally about all these formatting
options and there's a separate notebook
with lots of things to discuss in it
okay I have amended the options at the
bottom yet I think they're probably all
necessary but does someone need
permissions to store the data into a
notebook what are we talking about why
why are you asking that it's the
original reason kind of like why I got
invited to this meeting was for store
data set into notebook a little button
that was gonna go down here no you don't
need permission to it you are using the
notebook okay um I I do think frame and
frame style and so on a super useful I
think spacing is less useful I mean I
don't know these may not be you know if
we do a good job with the defaults it's
not so critical
it's another agenda item we don't have
currently any versioning information and
data set cells might as well put them in
might as well put it in yep
that's important is that working now
yeah yeah what happens if you have a
dataset where it hasn't stored all its
data in the notebook what does it do
it says Ziggy's your message something
like the date is not available okay it
does essentially the same thing that
summary box is June okay question from
Seth on the spinning beach balls on
large data sets yes we are worried about
that and we have to you know try and get
our act together so that doesn't happen
second question is if you normal a
sorted data set is it sorted
no the sorting is only a display so
here's what we need
just like with manipulate okay we need a
pace down this thing right so just like
in a manipulate you have you know you
move all the sliders around and then it
can paste a a version of the manipulate
right if I'm making sense so actually
place a version of the of the of the
content of the manipulate with those
settings set so I think this needs to be
able
to paste a dataset with those settings
set so what for example what alighted
columns do would they disappear well
that gives an argument for hide versus
remove and remove there would be no UI
it's just gone and it wouldn't be useful
unless you were to do the resolve this
data set I mean it would be useful if
you are looking at a data set and you've
just got a ton of stuff there and just
don't want any of it you say remove
remove remove remove for the sake of
essentially doing an operation that you
can then copy down yeah I mean I kind of
liked that idea I really like that idea
actually it's more useful probably
removal it's probably more useful for
ROS than for columns now you know okay
taking a leaf out of the insanities of
excel okay I mean every time I use Excel
I'm confused because of the whole
business about can I type down can I
type now what's gonna happen right so
one thing we could do in this theory
that what you see would be what you get
is have a right-click menu that allows
you to edit a cell to I'm saying and it
simply brings up an editor there it's
not the way that you want to enter you
know if you're doing a giant data entry
project it's not the way you want to do
it and your Excel the reason it's
awkward is that it has a lot of stuff
that's optimized for you no data entry
where it's you know Auto completing and
all this kind of stuff right mm-hmm
which is you know that's can be what
table View does but here I suggest that
what we do is we actually do allow you
know sort of you can adjust what you see
and you know just like you can adjust a
slider and if you were to reevaluate it
okay so this is a question visitor
dataset an input or a dataset an output
well most data sets are an output but
you could have a data set an input and
the question is then what does this do
if you adjust these things and I would
argue that the very nice thing for it to
do is if it's an input then those
adjustments if you press shift enter
they become real and if you have a data
set an output well the natural thing
that we would do in the front end is if
you make a change it copies down and
becomes the data set an input but I'm
not sure we want to do that by default
because I think a lot of these things
are merely like like manipulate doesn't
copy down right so I think the correct
behavior is it doesn't copy down by
default but there is a menu item that
does get it to copy down but we provide
a variety of sort of editing
functionality that allows you to go in
and change things but those don't become
permanent unless you copy it down and
conceivably or presumably if you just
evaluate it there would be the same kind
of cursor yes yeah yeah I think that's
correct yes
um yes so Ethan is commenting and I
agree that there are a whole bunch of
these things we need that when you right
click on a cell you should be able to
get the query you should certainly be
able to get the part for that cell and I
think we already have that functionality
based the path yes okay so this is an
old agenda item and I don't know how
much of it has been done or what remains
to be done some some of these items
already have special formats
I think interval could do with having a
special format other than that I think
I'm fine with these okay so who would
determine what the interval formatting
would look like we have special
formatting in quantity for interval so
we could take that okay
is that special formatting for your
position yes okay so that's not in the
list here so you better look at the code
Chris and find out what else there's but
this looks like it isn't broken what
does that mean
what is locking mean this was your
suggestion you should be able to
determine like click on a header and say
don't let this column scroll only for
the leftmost ones what does that mean it
means if you scroll all the other
columns would scroll but that one would
stay put so the the key is currently
behaved that way they don't scroll away
but you were asking to be able to
designate columns as well that wouldn't
screw
oh gosh that seems surplus to
requirements that seems very ornate yeah
I don't really see the use of it and
spreadsheets don't have that typically
as far as I know
heroes I've never learnt to use a
spreadsheet in a sophisticated way in
all these years I've never needed to
Jose I mentioned this earlier you do
equal on data sets they're not equal
because of this ID information what is
that idea information it's essentially a
pointer to a cache it shouldn't be there
yeah it's just wrong you asked for this
a way to make it work like image we can
change the options
yeah well that's what's been commented
on multiple times oh that's a cool idea
from Ethan if you highlight multiple
cells give you the optimal pattern I
would say that's a great summer school
project give you the optimal pattern and
selection conditions that will get you
those cells what a good summer school
project first we need a way of
highlighting cells can't currently do
that right can Cicero can you remind me
to add that to the list yep um oh boy
do we care that seems to me like a very
old native thing I mean grid has never
had that I could see where it might be
useful I mean sometimes does Excel have
that I don't know I mean there's only
two
there's only rows of columns in Excel
but
I think this is surplus to requirements
here for now I think it's cool but I
think we shouldn't worry about it right
now these are examples we're changing
some things result in surprising
reorganizations of the data set
why does it to it in this case I have no
idea
I'm gonna have to ask tally well I mean
I don't think it's a well I mean it may
be you may consider the bug but it's
intentional
I think this is depending on the type
that is computed for the data and
because the type is history dependent
sometimes the same data depending on how
you arrived at it formats differently oh
no there's a difference here in one case
the keys and the Association are
integers in other case they're strings
that's what causes the difference yes
but I'm saying is that even for the same
thing oh yeah so I'll tell you why this
is happening okay the reason this is
happening is because it is the
assumption that if there's strings that
they have a chance to be longer yeah
although that's finally by the fact that
this is actually the numeric Keys one so
I don't understand that that seems well
this seems kind of wacky to me probably
I'll tally this case you get different
layouts depending on how many elements
you're displaying which seems kind of
weird well I think they're going to be
breakpoints of that type somewhere I
don't know I'm not totally horrified I
mean to me this is in the category of it
isn't totally broken right now
never tables how would we do that I have
no idea it sounds like a bigger project
to me it's just an agenda item that you
threw out okay but I mean so that's more
of an operation on the whole data set
that is an important thing but we should
think about it separately yeah okay
nested data sets this is another it was
in your notes do we have to eat support
nested data sets right now yeah you can
you can make nested data sets like at
that example okay what's wrong with
these well it probably informs how we do
the scrolling so a data set nested
inside a data set the inner data set
doesn't get scroll bars right right sted
it goes to notice Billy it goes to this
form the inner data set goes to the you
know total whatever form okay now one of
the issues with this is let's say the
inner day set was really big you don't
just want you know a thousand total ten
thousand total you press it and kaboom
see what I'm saying
so well I suppose what
we do in that case is you click to get
that data set let's see whether actually
works
reevaluate that's not super encouraging
I can't seem to swing oh it's not okay
those are not functional in there okay I
hadn't actually tried that yeah so I
mean that would be the obvious thing to
do you click to get that you've got
drill down and then it gives you a
scrollable thing but I think you know I
think there's a limit if this says ten
thousand total it probably shouldn't
open you know first time honestly what
that should do is another one of these
hover menus if that's big you know if
it's small if it's like ten or something
you just do it but if it's really big I
think it needs to give you a hover menu
saying what do you want to do
I'm gonna have to go soon here but but
um so we have a nail down the syntax for
specifying for example formats of
internal items but when we do operations
like take we'll have to monkey with
those paths in order to preserve the
appearances of things so you can open up
all those cells to see example what's
your point well so if you if you take
all but the first row and column of that
data said you want what you want to get
is what's in the last output there but
that means changing the syntax of those
that option because the paths are
different now for the background so
you're saying you're assuming that you
want to lock the formatting to elements
rather than lock it to you know line
printer paper so to speak right yeah by
the way Ethan on live stream is pointing
out the exporting of data set to SQL
dumps which I don't believe we have
export to an Access database thing
that's another thing Sushma that will be
a thing for the database team I think
mm-hmm
I think I'm not sure I don't know how
the access maybe it's a question for a
thing for shaadi and the export stuff
okay I don't really understand this one
and this one to me but do you understand
the behavior that I understand the
behavior I'm not sure what behavior one
wants I mean I kind of think that by the
time you're doing a raw take on the data
set
earlier the formatting just disappears
well then that's fine for now I mean I
think that's a vision - okay I mean I
think what we want to do is an item
style type mechanism for individual
items and if your item didn't get zapped
you keep the formatting and if it didn't
I I don't know I think this is
complicated because this is this is very
similar let me give you an analogy this
is very similar and you should talk to
Charles about this it's very similar to
what happens with graphs where you've
decorated a graph and then you do
operations on the graph and Charles
introduced in version 12 a kind of
calculus of a calculus of carrying along
attributes okay yeah like a few Union
two graphs do carry along the the colors
of the of the nodes and so on yeah talk
to Charles about this okay yeah well
eventually what we want to be able to do
and I think this is a useful thing is
when you give the header information
when you construct the data set or you
give options to it to be able to say
actually I don't want Mercury Venus
Earth to be laid out at all like this I
just want them to be tabs at the top
right we could call them tabby data sets
like tabby cats
my name porting datasets I'm not sure
what that means importing from where
this is an item from you if you have
like a CSV file that has a blank line on
it that you would preserve that in the
data set it certainly seems like a
version to a feature in the version to
feature for sure it's a version to
feature pagination so there was a
pagination option on your original
agenda I don't think it's relevant
anymore and I don't think it's relevant
item yeah and this is the idea that that
you show the structure of that data set
by with the style of the frame lines you
can open that second output that's
magnificent that's magnificent so
there's a styled data set are you saying
is it is that a styled data set no the
point is that you're showing how that
table is structured I mean this is what
table form should have should I mean if
table form wasn't a version one function
it would do things like this and
arguably should be updated to do this
because she understand
form just actual raw spaces between if
you do a three-dimensional table it'll
use actual raw spaces there let's see
access spans it says access plans on
both x and y zoom into a sub matrix yeah
the whole sub matrix thing we need to
write down to talk about sub matrices
but it's version 2 um yeah a semantic
import big complicated thing we'll work
on it we have some big ideas for that
all right so we failed to resolve stuff
at the beginning about how to represent
elision how to represent this items
displayed thing I think we need another
meeting about that if you had can have a
think about that that would be good but
I think we're we're talking about that
and the elision stuff that's really what
we need to do and the entire formatting
I mean lots of issues around the
formatting options which involve this
some of the same issues ok of
representing paths and how we specify
things yeah yeah ok well let's get
another meeting set up um and yeah
anything else here um good that's that
should be that Sushma are you around
later could I give you a call a bit
later um ok thanks to everybody and
thanks to folks on the livestream very
useful comments much appreciated and I
look forward to don't leave it too long
for another meeting in this series
please otherwise you'll have to tell me
everything again I think my my memory
decay time for this will be on the order
of a week
okay okay thanks
sounds good see you're very nice very
nice stuff Chris thanks thanks okay bye